yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing 11 from the us- manas must go
against okay so let's see what we can do
here in depth the Keener's variation of
the english only be six I don't quite
know how this is all this line is sub
heading out yeah does he threaten this
should have three I don't think he is
one ok so clean what to do here Clint
eggs on pawn takes after pawn takes I'm
not quite sure when a king is going to
be positioned on the other hand that
looks like a very dynamic option I think
I'm doing this not sure about it ok i
know we should be 52 the crudest threat
ever but you can try so the shrimp gt5
he he decided on that really quickly and
it looks pretty bad ok so i could
actually play should be for a queen a
form c5 is also very decent move he will
probably ok let's do this and I don't
want to spend now ages on that now here
I am for Queen a phone or queen a 4
immediately maybe this is true
actually because between a seven is also
a flat yet it is stronger so i can take
on a seven potentially yeah you can also
just put it here let's do it
he didn't waste any time I'll just
dashing out to move after move it really
all that simple ok now I can take with
threaten 360 easy now is something like
rock d1 Bishop g5 I'm winning materially
anyway the question is what is the best
way to win it captioning long haul so I
don't know what's better cancelling long
or lucky one ok I'm going T 1 ok I can
already take on these six which
definitely win some material can also
take on these exhibition to five wins
material I wonder what's best it's not
easy to say I would love to prevent him
from castling really i wonder if i can
do that somehow but should be five my
valuable castle
okay I'll take here I mean I just have
to take into account that is blitzing i
remove and i will have problems with the
time anyway this is also why i take is
probably not the best move but it's
easier to manage settings c5 now winning
the winning apiece ok let's see i guess
it will go before just irritate know
this one that's probably better move
came covering this
yes ready for landing a jetta pretty
much lost ending but I just want one
minute which makes it not so easy much
was lost put me too strong look aged
three maybe let some counterplay look is
very oxide they also will thin
c7 King Bishop d7 and wins apiece but
can I win quicker somehow
[Music]
23 seconds hopefully easing Jeff
especially being in that somewhat rusty
stayed under check check you have to go
with my own see porn of course check
check check check check check check
[Music]
check mate John once in a while playing
a good new health let's just put it like
that okay so if we had this opening and
I'm not quite sure here let me switch
this on cam here Episode III is just I
don't want to play a song that we should
be too yeah taking this as I don't know
i don't like it i just don't like it now
see that gives up too much light squares
the bishop pair my phone structure is
not great i know it's still important
thing is that I'm threatening Bishop g5
the Enders to
he cannot just play whatever for example
this Bishop c5 the sugar-free and this
this is an important technical trick the
Queen I was trapped he actually has this
this thing that yeah continuous the game
at least but it's not very good but note
that something something like this would
completely do that I mean I'm sorry come
on yeah I now he would have to give the
cleaner like Bishop g2 or something so I
mean he took clean cake was possible as
well and yeah he quickly decided on this
and now g6 you know I know I think h6 is
better we are the engine already thinks
that like it's pretty much in bad shape
I wasn't sure about the exact move order
but I think I've hit the hit on the
engine moves Bishop c6 might be better i
am might be better but does this cannot
be all and all a terrible I mean the
whole game was very very clear just just
the time spent i was trying to like win
by made or so but i didn't find anything
c5 looks like a good move yes that's
absolutely true opening opening this up
what what am i doing against this I had
to take here and then looked you won
okay external it just prevents be 56
okay so this is what I did and now I
have a various moves I also saw this one
they of course takes takes this opens up
my queen but I didn't see a win it's
very good between age for Bishop g5 also
wins wins
but this wasn't so clear yeah I saw that
and he is he's getting this and this
isn't clear this is why I went with this
castles and now I was fairly sure i
added the engine movies better we should
be treated I thought this is simpler to
play and I'm giving our F I have lost
some of the advantage him yeah but this
is clearly wrong but I didn't review it
right Luke t7 was was even stronger here
than the check okay okay I'm down to one
minute okay that was seeing as anything
as we're ending is very good for me Luke
takes off probably stronger okay can you
fix kingdom and just ending is a win but
to you have to do it in the time and
probably have made some conversion
mistakes yeah here for example the fta
seven isn't the best one kingi to King
d3 and from there again but why isn't
this heaven good let me check it this
does look to h4 aha why is quick enough
he's quick enough to get here I didn't
see you get four of course I wanted to
do this but now we can actually take
because the route can cover that so that
would have saved him again who gauge for
would food safe and this is losing no
check check check okay that is when the
only question is can I do it in 12
seconds
okay guys thanks for watching